tokyo avengers has some of the most
awe-inspiring moments and some great
characters that we meet throughout this
ever-enveloping series but as it is with
all life eventually it must come to an
end and sadly throughout tokyo avengers
we are constantly reminded of that fact
even though takamichi has the
opportunity and ability to save some
people and does on multiple occasions he
simply can't save them all in this video
we are going to go over each character
of the tokyo revenges that is confirmed
to have passed away and in no possible
way can be saved by takamichi and his
time-leaping ability so watch out as
there is obviously going to be some
massive spoilers quickly though before
we get into the video if you are new in
here and want to keep up to date with
the latest tokyo avengers and other
anime content then make sure to hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as well as it
really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but enough of that let's
get into each of the permanent deaths
that happen throughout the tokyo
adventures series
[Music]
i think the best way to go about each of
these deaths is i guess start from where
the root of all the trouble began with
the death of mikey's older brother
shinochiro sano during 2003 in august
kesuki baji and kasura hanamiya decided
to steal a bike for mikey's birthday and
this was because of how mikey had
recently been driving around on his
moped street hawk edition which made the
group look extremely lame mikey ended up
trashing the bike and beating up a bunch
of other delinquents who were trying to
fight baji while he was protecting it
this is where it brings us to baji and
kasatura who decided to break into a
motorbike shop so that they could steal
mikey's dream suzuki cb250t
sadly after the young kazutura breaks
into the shop with baji they get spotted
by shinichiro sano who as i've said is
the older brother of mikey and is also
the leader of the first generation black
dragons shinichiro notices bhaji and
tells him that this is his bike shop and
asks him why he is here while this is
happening kazutura who had snuck off
hadn't realized that they were
technically safe and are completely
mistaken whose shop they were robbing
and as shinichiro is talking to baji
kazatura runs up behind him and smacks
him over the back of the head with the
bolt cutters he'd used to cut the chain
on the bike previously sadly baji had
realised at the last second what was
about to happen and screamed out for
kazutoru to stop but it was too late
shinochiro sano suffered a facal wound
to the back of the head and lay on the
floor slowly losing life hearing the
sound of police sirens outside kazutoro
realizes that he's messed up and
completely loses it he starts to break
down mentally and even thinks that he
has to kill mikey now to fix everything
spiking the star of later events in the
series though this here on the 14th of
august 2003 is the first permanent death
of the tokyo avengers story moving on
these later events that are sparked
happen after two years and sadly result
and probably one of the craziest deaths
in the entire series this is the death
of kasuki baji best friend of kazatura
the former leader of tomen's first
division and a founding member of the
tokyo manji gang after leaving tomon
under the ruse of joining the new
valhalla gang it is revealed through
shifuyu the vice president of division
one that baji has actually left toumen
to try and save kazatura and figure out
whether or not kisaki tessa is truly
trying to corrupt mikey during the
valhalla vs tomen fight baji gets
stabbed by kazutora and after fighting
off a bunch of valhalla's fodder
delinquents he collapses it turned out
that kazutora after realizing that baji
hadn't ever truly left tomen and that it
was all technically a ruse to try and
save him had stabbed him out of rage to
takamichi's demise everything was
playing out like hisaki had wanted and
it looked as though mikey was going to
kill kasatura just like he had in the
original timeline when suddenly to the
utter surprise of both takamichi and
shifuyu baji stood back up and said to
mikey you got mad just for me
thanks man baji then like a complete
badass walks towards mikey with blood
just pouring off him and talks about how
he ain't gonna die and that this wound
ain't gonna kill him he then flicks out
his knife and turns it on himself
thrusting it straight into his own gar
and with blood running out of his mouth
says to kasatura you are not gonna kill
me baji collapses and bleeds out in the
hands of shifuyu with some lovely final
words thanking him for everything and
through takamichi's determination he
gets baji's last words through to the
rage and thrilled maiki and kazutora is
saved from death because of this
adverting the dark timeline and
defeating kisaki's plans once again the
next permanent death in the series takes
place over 100 chapters after the last
and is probably in my own opinion the
saddest in the entire series or so far
at least as it involves the beloved
sister of sano manjiro this is the death
of imasano her death comes about after
kisaki realizes that at every single
turn takamichi has constantly been there
to stop him so he reverts to the worst
possible idea as he is backed into a
corner with the help of emma's
half-brother izana kisaki set up someone
who would take the fall for her death
and set out on a motorbike to kill her
himself
after mikey leaves both emma and
takamichi together he enters the
graveyard to say hello to his deceased
older brother shinachudo and confront
izana who had appeared there as well
while leaving with emma takamichi comes
to a huge realization that he hadn't yet
thought of what if emma isn't around in
the future as he's thinking this he
hears the sound of a motorbike slowly
approaching from the distance looking
over he notices that kisaki is on the
back holding a baseball bat takamichi
thinking he's the target puts up his
hands to block but as the bike nears it
flies past and kisaki hits emma over the
side of the head knocking her to the
ground hearing the sound of a rolling
can bunt the back of his foot takamichi
turns around to see emma bleeding from
the head and kisaki glaring back while
driving off from a distance running over
and grabbing emma takamichi realizes
that if emma dies right now he can't
save her as he screams out for her to be
okay mikey rounds the corner from the
graveyard and sees that emma's seemingly
lifeless body as in takamichi's hands
mikey immediately picks up emma and puts
her on his back after being completely
stunned by the situation at hand as he's
telling emma about the earlier times in
their life while he is doing this msa is
tamaki please tell draken i love you
draken tell him that
and with tears in her eyes and a smile
on her face asks takamichi to please
take care of mikey emma then passes away
on the back of your older brother
sending him into a spiral of utter
despair the fourth permanent death of
this series is also another member of
mikey's expanded family and involves the
leader of the 8th generation black
dragons and the former president of
tijuku before his untimely death this is
the death of izana kudakawa during the
tenjiku vs tomen battle maki had
confronted izana about the death of emma
and asked him why he killed their sister
after being defeated by tomin kokucho
tried to get izana to snap out of the
rage that he was in screaming that
tenjiku had lost while he's screaming
this out kisaki who had just picked up
izana's handgun shoots kakucho in the
back splattering blood onto the face of
izana kokucho while coughing up blood
turns around and charges at kisaki who
is about to unload the entire clip into
kokucho when out of nowhere to the utter
surprise of every single person there
isana grabs kakucho and throws him out
of the way in a similar way to baji
dying so that someone else wouldn't have
to as he pushes kukucho out of the way
kisaki shoots three shots which all
directly hit izana's chest and stomach
kisaki who hadn't realized that izana
had jumped in the way before his shot is
left in shock at the sight that he just
shot izana izana says to kakucho that
his body just moved on its own and tells
mikey the truth about how he technically
isn't even related to mikey shinichito
and emma as he met his apparent mother
who turned out to be just some woman who
had taken care of him after his father
had died as he's on a lazier on the
ground bleeding out he asked mikey so
you wanted to save me before saying
there is no way to save me right
realizing the uncomparable way of the
situation he was in and the reality that
his death was approaching faster than he
wanted izana then struggles to get out
his last words and with a whisper he
says
right ma he then passed away
moving on from the surprising death of
izana this next permanent death here is
probably and i think obviously the most
important death of this series so far
this here is the death of the main
antagonist of tokyo avengers and the
mastermind behind all future outcomes
the death of kisaki teter instantly
after shooting and killing izana kisaki
is picked up by hanma and thrown onto
the back of the bike as they both speed
off to escape but takamichi hops on the
back of draken's bike and gives chase
because kisaki was being super impatient
he made hanma crash and slide his bike
along the ground takamichi and dragon
arrived to confront kisaki but as they
go to grab him he runs off draken helps
takamichi chase down kisaki again
because of the bullet wound takamichi
had suffered to the foot stopping him
from being able to run properly
eventually after a few more difficulties
takamichi is finally able to track down
kisaki and they go into an all-out fist
fight after an extremely close fight
where the two brawl on the ground
takamichi has his first ever future
sight as he sees a future in which
kisaki asks hina to marry him but she
ends up rejecting him this in turn gives
us as readers the reasoning for
waikisaki wanted to kill hina that being
she rejected him a simple but extremely
human emotion kisaki then pulls the same
gun on takamichi that he used to kill
izana not that long ago but when kisaki
is about to pull the trigger takamichi
does something that was completely
unexpected and like mikey does an
insanely quick straight up kick that
sends the gun flying out of kysaki's
hand before he could even pull the
trigger after the gun falls to the
ground takamichi picks it back up and
aims it at the main antagonist of the
series takamichi contemplates shooting
and killing kasaki as it would solve all
the issues and save hana but before he
shoots both heena and mikey show up and
takamichi turns his head to see them
this gives kasaki the time to quickly
run off to escape getting caught though
he shouldn't have done this as takamichi
chases him down he finds and catches him
standing in the middle of a road
crossing as kasaki turns his head to say
to takamichi you still think i'm a time
leaper a truck speeding down the road
comes out of absolutely nowhere and hits
kasaki directly seeing him flying across
the pavement and cracking the top of his
head open as he hits the ground along
with probably breaking the majority of
his ribs one arm and one leg
immediately kisaki begins to scream out
that he doesn't want to die and tries to
stand back up but can't as his body is
too badly broken he then collapses
bleeding out on this street with
takamichi hina and mikey all standing
there in utter disbelief
the final permanent death of this series
involves another member of tomen the
fifth division captain joshua muto
though this death in my own personal
opinion doesn't have as much of an
implication on the story as the previous
as it's done more or less in secret
after the tinjuku vs tomen incident muto
was sentenced to six months in juvenile
prison and after being released he was
picked up by no one other than sanzu the
vice president of the fifth division and
a supposed close friend of muso after
driving moto to the docks sanzu tells
him that he had been wasting for this
day and pulls out of his bag a samurai
sword and slices moto across his chest
he tells muto that he was fooling him
this entire time and that his goal was
always to protect mikey so when he
betrayed mikey and left homan to become
a traitor for tenjuku he knew that he
had to be killed or at least that's how
sanzu interpreted this situation but
anyway i hope you all enjoyed the video
and learned a bit perhaps about the
moments leading up to the points of all
the permanent deaths throughout tokyo
avengers so far i put a bunch of work in
this video so if you have enjoyed it and
want to see more then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure
to leave a like on the video then drop a
comment down below with what you all
thought about the video and what you'd
like me to go over next but anyway for
now spin your professional degenerate
diavolo and i'll see you all in a bit
bye
you